[Music]
this is
is that a song did they make a song is
this is this a song
is there a song why is there a song or
is this like
i don't know if it's the same one but i
posted
uh a saw one of their songs in the show
links
i also posted uh they have a bear atari
website for their times whatever it's
called
and an apple page so this this is a song
for pretoria
all right
[Music]
it's getting crazy
no
[Music]
what no yes this is the victoria song
it's really cool bro relax
this covington because i know coddington
does bad music
no the la the last the last movement
is the channel the last movement no but
who wrote but that doesn't mean that
just
look these guys all upload each other's
[ __ ] content
i want to know who made this song
it's got to be coddington right the song
was inspired by owen benjamin and the
bears
uh no the last movement is is a per is
just a guy how could you oh no how could
you
watch this and be like man we're part of
a cool group of guys well
this is kick ass as one of the top
comments uh
let's see here uh those cougarettes are
crushing keep crushing moomin
uh this is so good i dare say legendary
legendary crushing
i i'm i'm uh dude
we're back to just i'm actually just
being really embarrassed
what is this vocal inflection i i don't
know
um apparently he's building a home
something he could call his own
but this this the vocal inflicted
singing it's so [ __ ] weird i have
spin out of this owen loop for so long
no but this is good because then when we
come back it's like wow that's a lot of
built-in i feel like
yeah it's kind of like you know like
with me with like trying to track my
weight loss right
if you pay attention every day it's like
it's grueling
but if you just check back every week
like you told me to do it's like you go
oh yeah look at me i'm doing good
but if you're just looking it's about
why other people will notice you've lost
weight
because they go wow you lost weight and
you go i don't know maybe a little bit
it's like well you're just looking at
yourself every day
they see you in two weeks and go wow you
look great so it's like owen's one of
those or if you just look away for a
while and come back you go
oh wow you've gotten increasingly
crazier or it's like when
when a new season of a show comes out
and you're like i'll just watch it when
the whole episode season comes out
it's more secret right so you can binge
instead of having to wait week to week
yeah we've binge owen benjamin he's like
a netflix show
okay so i found more songs oh no
is the killer one is he oh the official
one okay got it i got it i got it
i've got dreams
give it a second it just started why are
you laughing give it a [ __ ] you're not
even giving it a shot
you're not giving it a shot
oh [ __ ] this one's gonna be way better i
can feel it
give it a shot just give it a shot it's
okay okay
i've got dreams
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
how close we aria would have been better
would have rhymed at least
[Music]
oh
i'm getting owl city vibes yeah yeah
yeah you're right that's something i
feel like i'm listening to or maybe like
imagine dragons
little magic dragons yeah maybe softs
the beast a b
side coldplay song yeah or maybe uh
sunny day real estate remember that dude
that's a good one that nice point
nice pull yes that was that sunny day
real estate is the band i couldn't think
of last week
when i had that brain fart in this sunny
day real estate
this really sounds like owl city in in a
bizarre way though
this is how city are they secretly based
this is let's see who this is this is
anchor bear anchor bear
this is so bad so tell me what
you all messed up there's some rap
it's one of these there's a little bit
of rap
it's one of these it's just a little bit
of rap it's not a lot of rap
confused each month they got a new
[Music]
[Laughter]
i'm sorry adderall
why are people like this
um fatherless homes if somebody did a
song
like this about us you would be gone
you'd be out of here i can't stop
finding these
hey can you stop finding these yeah
seriously
what do you you know what this is
frozen's revenge yeah [ __ ] you're right
another one frozen's revenge all right
i'll play it here we go
a little more hard i like it i like it
[Applause]
[Music]
but wait for it to kick in
[Music]
yeah but who does it sound like it
sounds like a specific fan hold on
did cage the elephant make this elephant
i was thinking honestly sounds a little
bit like mud honey okay mud honey that's
[Music]
i fair their tired cliche analogies too
oh my god how did you find these frozen
did you know what i haven't heard that i
haven't heard anybody
uh equate something to a castle being
built in sand before
oh that's pretty deep a thousand times
in a song yeah some people are saying
kind of the offspring
i see offspring i see offspring a really
shitty off thing
[Music]
i gave to owen cause i got no
self-esteem
oh yeah see
dr brony i think missed my joke i
already said i feel like an aew wrestler
is coming out
uh green day we're getting green day
vibes newfound glory
this will be [ __ ] sammy guevara's new
entrance theme
[Music]
what i if i were owen benjamin like
given his fan base and how bad they are
and everything i would be like can you
guys just stop
stop doing things i found another one
okay enough stop doing things owen songs
are a genre what is happening
principled says in the chat i don't know
we are now
just discovering that this is apparently
we didn't know this was a thing
but now we're very much regretting
finding out this is a thing
[Music]
how many songs is anchor bear going to
write about bear tario
[Music]
are they going to be doing iron working
in their terrier
[Music]
oh god
[Music]
we'll drink ourselves to death and beat
our wives
[Music]
like look look i do think that given
that the current world climate
it's not stupid to be prepared and to
learn these skills and to to know stuff
but like
i'm so sick of this meme that these
people
that think that going back to living
like this would be so
cool like you know what i mean like the
people that actually fantasize about
like
yeah we should go back to living in a
christian theocracy and plow in the
fields and i'm like that sounds
[ __ ] horrible and yeah you should
learn how to do that stuff
if the [ __ ] hits the fan you might want
to know how to grow some [ __ ] basic
carrots and tomatoes
and maybe keep some chickens alive so
you can eat and survive
but when they when they try to glorify
it like yeah man
this is what real men do man it's farm
all day
like that sounds [ __ ] terrible